Yes, I would like to welcome you
to our current philosopher, Immanuel
Kant, and I can
assure you right away that Immanuel Kant is one of the
most important philosophers of all. In
the eighteenth century, he made
two major discoveries that
still keep us in suspense today
categorical imperative,
which you all know from
school, mostly from
German lessons and on the other hand, and
that was perhaps even
more important, he was the very first to answer an
age-old question in human history
, namely the question of
how cognitions come about in our heads at all
, how
does our mental apparatus work  how
do we get to certain truths and
insights and he answered this question in
his main work in the critique of
pure reason over 1000 pages you
see here they appeared here in two
volumes which would not work in one volume
and in this work is
actually  a very large and
important literary piece of the
entire history of philosophy he
asks the question what can our
reason recognize at all and what not therefore
critique of pure reason
he says the whole philosophy whose
quote from immanuel kant philosophy is
teeming with faulty definitions
and the reason for this is  quite simply
that people all
see the same reality, yes we
all live on the same earth, but the
crucial thing is that through
mistakes in reasoning and wrong logical conclusions, we
then come to completely different
definitions and opinions and
insights and we can
no longer tolerate that and  that's why he
asked this radical question how
does the thinking apparatus work and how
do we come to absolutely correct
knowledge
and that had been examined on over 1000
pages the decisive thing is now what
is also important for us that can
even at the age of 46 didn't
want any more half-truths v  he gave himself up and
didn't write a single book anymore,
no more articles, nothing anymore,
although as a professor he was actually
obliged to constantly
issue new publications no, he
didn't write anything anymore, he withdrew
to his study room
and actually only worked on this one
question worked how does our
mental apparatus work
he had his servant wake him up every morning with iron
discipline
with the words it is time and
when he got up still in his dressing gown working
towards his
lectures back then he only
went for a short
walk in the afternoon  otherwise iron
and that dear students for eleven
years and only after eleven years did
he give mankind his answer
yes how the human mental apparatus
works and i have
another quote here the critique of pure
reason
yes this book the main work then
understands he said  I understand  this
does not include criticism of books and systems,
but that of reason in
general, the point is that he doesn't
want to criticize other philosophers in any way, but rather he wants to
ask critically what reason can
actually achieve and that is
a very, very important question, so I think
it is  it's always difficult to make young people understand the radical nature of
this question
, so
i'll try it now with a
very specific example,
you all here in the hall have
sensory impressions, you smell, you hear,
you see and you maybe feel
the pressure of your chairs, yes, you
have high  sensory impressions everyone here me
too you see, for example,
this deep blue here you see the gold you
you hear larynx sounds so i use my
larynx to produce loud sounds in the form
of speech of course but first of
all you only hear the telecom lull then
you see
black signs here black and white  these are
other sensory impressions they smell
a bit of dry air here in the hall and
then maybe you will still feel the
pressure from the chair because yes, well, our
chairs are not that kind of thing now
, yes, and that all these
sensory impressions get into your head at the same time
, now
that could be the case  you sit there and everything gets mixed
up blue gold edge buttocks hurt white
signs acoustic noises everything is
mixed up but it's not like that when I
ask you now why are you here yes
why why are you here yes yes you are
listening to a lecture on edge and
maybe you are sitting too  uncomfortable chair and that's a realization that's a realization
when someone says i'm listening to a
lecture on immanuel kant and are sitting
on a somewhat uncomfortable chair
then you've already processed all these
sensory experiences
in a short time in an
orderly manner and are closed
came a realization but how did
that happen it
always happens lightning fast and that's it  so the
interesting thing is not
just about how the scientist
can formulate exact knowledge
and come to the right results with the thinking apparatus
, but also how we
process all the pictures, smells, sounds in every second of our life that's what
it's about in the acknowledged
he says all our knowledge catches  with
the experience and then there is absolutely
no doubt
that all our cognition starts with the
experience there is no
doubt about it so it always starts with the fact
that we have some kind of experience
because
how else should the cognitive faculty be awakened to exercise
if it does not happen through
the objects  that touch our senses
so he says it always starts like this there is
some object this wall of the
sheet of gold something touches my
senses and that’s how the
whole experience
begins and our thinking apparatus also begins to
be stimulated so at the starting point there are
always some objects
good against  nds that stir our senses
and set our intellectual activity in
motion compare
them, link them or separate them and thus process
the high material of sensual impressions into
a cognition now
it gets exciting when he says in the beginning there are
always such high sensory impressions high
sensory impressions dry air  I myself
what I hear what I see what but these
calm impressions are then
processed at lightning speed and they
set our intellectual activity in
motion yes so they stir the senses
and set intellectual activity in
motion to compare these we
compare the objects at lightning speed
we separate  and connect what
is meant by that how does
our mind separate and connect the objects
i will now give you a very
simple example when we
wake up in the morning suppose you are
sleeping wonderfully and wake up
and
listen to what you are doing and what
you are doing  she always on when she au  f was
cell phone alarm clock exactly and then you hear
the squeaking or beeping or race yes
that's the first thing you hear that a
pure calm sensory impression then
you maybe even
wink a bit then you
are dazzled because it's already daylight
you see  the curtain is a crack
the sun shines in
your eyes your nose smells the smell of coffee you smell
that maybe your girlfriends if you're
lucky have already made coffee
then you hear something chirping and you notice
where the birds are chirping that noise
then you might notice it  a
nice day and then you
start to organize your sensual impressions with your head
because at first
you only hear the squeaking and that
is the beeping of the alarm clock and
nothing else and
you have to assign this calm sensual impression that
you can also  its a mouse it beeps
it can be a rattlesnake it
can be a train that drives by and it
squeaks i have it once  al managed
to classify the alarm clock as a train noise in the
dream then overslept
which dreamed and authorities that should
be another train past where is
reality the way so also but also
when you wake up and that is what
he says when you wake up then
compare  then connect and
disconnect yes and we hold it
maybe it's between a
rattlesnake
or you think it's the squeaking of the
mouse but the moment you open your eyes
you see what's disgusting
and then you see the alarm clock and then
disconnect  they say no it's not an
animal it's plastic it's an alarm clock
and then you can compare sort it out
and separate that's what the mind
does and now there's something
really exciting I'll go back to
all our activities or our
perception he says  can starts
with arranging things spatially
when we wake up in the
morning we have no other chance than
that we see everything spatially because now he
has a thesis that i
will show you in a moment the space is
a necessary a
priori conception that underlies all external perceptions
so when we wake up we see,
for example, the alarm clock on the
bedside table after that there is a piece of the table
away from the bed then we see the window
then we are the curtain gap where
it is again two meters fifty away from the
bed and we can see these distances
next to each other on top of each other
but why can we
see them and then kant says the
condition of the possibility that we can do everything
arrange spatially so that we can see
exactly that it is next to or on
top of each other that we have spatial
imagination and that is why he
says here the space is an a
priori conception that underlies all perceptions so everything
external that we see who then 80 etc.
all external perceptions are only
possible because I already have spatial
thinking in me  r in it have the
computer freaks among you would sang
is pre-installed yes in our brain
pre-installed is the spatial
personal imagination so
what does a priori mean by the way space is a
necessary idea a priori would be
latin a
from prior we is the prior
the prior is the abbots the  first
the prayer leader the first the foremost the one in
front is so that means quasi a
priori means from the outset from the front
from the front
line or from the outset is
probably the best translation
because the space from the
outset is not only in our heads when we
open our eyes  it's already in there and
that's why we see it spatially
we can try it so he
makes a nice example there too
, let's take a look at it he says so that i
can
imagine the objects apart from each other the idea of ​​the space has to be the basis for this
and now he does it  what a nice thing
he says we can have a
counter  make an example imagine
some object i'll
get another book yes not even the book would be
i have nothing else to it there yes
take this book now
try something try to imagine the book
without it being in a room
it's not possible you can
imagine that the book is gone you
can imagine in the room that is
completely empty where maybe there isn't
even the wall where I'm not probably
nothing but the room
itself is still in your head yes  so
we can't get rid of the space it's
impossible we can
maybe also do that we can
now imagine that the space is gone
here then we're standing under the open sky
but even if we're standing under the open
sky the sky is called the
clouds and  even if you think it because of
that then we are in the universe but
the spatial imagination itself
we will never get rid of it says he can
well well he says  you can never
imagine that there is no room at all
, although you
can imagine that there are no objects
in it so we can imagine going
to the library with half
the books or even no books
at all so we can use the objects
think outside of the room but we always think in terms of space
we can’t
get around it
and now comes the second
logically i have already revealed
the time is exactly the same phenomenon
also the time at the moment when we
wake up in the morning you have to
see if  not only that we
actually see everything, we also
throw a second filter
over reality and this second
filter, so to speak, with which we see the
world is pre-installed,
which means
we can't help but put everything in
such a
brutal order  very rigidly we all arrange his
first ringing then we hear birds
chirping then we see the vo  gel on
the window sill that flies away again
then riechmann café smell then
maybe i'll get up then i'll pull the
curtain up some people pull back
then i'll go out but sideways
good morning but one sport is called
in a chronological order you
can't  another way you can
do a cross-check try
just one day and/or do
we have to spend a quarter of an hour
without having any
perception of time you
will not succeed because you are constantly
perceiving rails of time you have when
i am here and doing  two three
steps over here then i was
here before now i'm here everything is in a
time continuum what i already have in it
and now comes a radical
conclusion from kant he says this
ab riorian look at space
and time i about reality
putting it
on leads to the fact that all objects of
the senses are in time and
necessarily so  standing in relationships
at the moment and something else that
is even more important what it is
about the objects themselves
and separated from our perception
so recipe ivi ity means
perception and our sensuality may have
remains completely unknown
it is understood that is completely, completely, completely
important point for kant this leads to
the sentence the thing in itself is not
recognizable he says what it is
about the objects
themselves we don't know at all so we don't know how
the alarm clock really is
or our room we see  everything only
under spatial-temporal
filters and we can't
switch off this filter how things really are
we don't know exactly we don't know
and that's why the thing in itself is
nothing recognize we always only recognize ourselves
through our filters is
radicalized he even says we
recognize  not or we don't know anything
so our own way of perceiving them
so we can't  it is our way of
perceiving things
that is peculiar to us that is also not
necessary to read to everyone whether
people have to come to our doctor of
perception does not have to come to every being
the bees, for example,
we don’t know whether they can see space and
time whether they can too  our mixing
visual forms have there are
scientific studies that the
bees even have a completely different
perception that the bees
that they see this pollen the
poles that are in metallic projects
can perceive things that we do
n't see at all they have completely different perceptions in the
world  and probably also a
different perception we don't know
yes and can says we know nothing
else than our way of perception
that comes to people to other beings
maybe we don't know but
one thing is certain even the bee ca
n't say like the flower  and
for itself really looks well the
bee can only say  the flower looks the
way i see it and we would see the
flower you might see it
completely differently how the flower really is
no one knows and that's the famous
sentence the thing itself can't be
recognized well here i
have you again  we brought a scheme with us so we brought
the object is everything we
see when we wake up then there
are high impressions coming our way
kant calls it sensuality yes and
these high are impressions the
smell what we hear what the
senses perceive the nose  what we
smell what we see all these
sensory impressions
are then provided with a grid
we slap our space-time
grid rigorously over all
objects and through this things arrange themselves
and that leads to knowledge but not
only that is just a part of the
knowledge for now  there is something
else to it the mind and the
thinking apparatus
here the realization is actually
produced i have ih  n yes,
given an example beforehand if we only had
the raw sensory impressions in space and
time we would not yet have any
knowledge then we would only have the
referent is here the referent is there yes
or we first thought the alarm clock would ring then
then appear brighter then then
smell but they have  no
realization the realization that i look at the alarm clock
and says it's already half past eight
i'll be late i have to get out quickly
or the realization the sun is shining
the birds are chirping it's going to be a warm
day i only put on a t-shirt that
's a lot  much more that's realisation,
since you're already taking a break,
thinking h that indicates warm
weather when the birds are chirping the sun is
shining so strongly and so i'm just
putting on a t-shirt that's quite
realisation,
and it's arising here and understanding
and the  by the way, we have the first part
that's an important part in this in
this book in the critique of in the
critique of pure reason yes
that's called  t the transcendental
aesthetics yes so the whole part here is
called transcendental aesthetics and
it describes the ab
riorian visual forms of space and time
aesthetics what does it mean
where are the greeks who speaks greek
it comes from does it say they say
that means the perception basically
and
ultimately it's only about the a
priori shen forms of perception and
we know the result yes the trans of the
transcendental it is also very
important misunderstood he is not concerned with
how it biologically works in our
heads  and where the spatial is
spatial thinking and the temporal
thinking is that doesn't matter he says what is
the condition of the possibility
that we perceive things spatially and temporally
that is the transcendental
philosophical approach and this
result we know the condition of the
possibility that we perceive everything spatially
to perceive time is the a priori the
fact that we ab riol frame time
sch  than having ideas in your head
and now we come to the mind now
we
come to the mind, namely how do we come to judge to
know he says the power of judgment
is the ability to think the particular contained
under the general it now
difficult sentence the power of judgment is the
ability that  special
to think under the general
what does that mean now that means
when we wake up
and then we hear this ringing then
we think of this noise as a
particular of the noise the particular
in different generalities we
think that could belong to the generality of the
descriptions of mice or to the
generality of the  clapping of trains
or for the generality of the film of electronic
devices
it could also be my mobile phone or something
and think that in different
generalities, however, if we then
open our eyes and also see
the square bleating then it is clear
if we still reach out and hit it
that's more likely  is silent  doesn't feel like
a mouse has no fur the quality
is different it's square that's
part of the generality of square
things and it's part of the generality
of electrical things and then
we very quickly identified it as an alarm clock
that's what he means
well then again  continue now what you
see in front of you here are the famous
twelve categories
interesting journey says immanuel
kant we have all these twelve categories in
his head and now we are approaching the
core of the critique of pure reason
he says every human being on earth
has these twelve categories  and
interestingly enough although only twelfth is
not so that you have ten i have
eleven and another has twelve the
next 15 no we all only have twelve
ways to think and in these
twelve categories every human
being thinks at lightning speed it's not
like that we  one category after the
other on walls this is often possible
at the same time but the condition d  he
possibility
that we will come
to an understanding is that we all think like that and that
eventually you realize he has these
you see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
so i told 19 11 2 and he has these
twelve
categories  in summary these are
the three categories of quantity so
when we wake up we also think
in quantities we think how much
is it how many things are around me
we think in unity in variety and
so on we hear many birds
chirping and so on  we think in terms of
quality yes we think in terms of
quality how does it feel is that
white that furry no is not furry
plastic is not a mouse yes we
think in quality
categories and we think
very strongly in relationships even we think
something in relationships  does it have to do with me
how is it all related because with the
relationships, for example, a very important
category is causality you think
about the category 6,700 times every day
orie of causality
even with every little thing yes there is
clearly the way is the battery
because then the battery contains feedback
or because you always think in categories
or because you see the pointer is
driven by the battery always at the
same speed now you know aha
hours always come right away aha it's
already 9 o'clock i have to go otherwise i'll be
too late you always think in terms of cause and
effect feelings or the birds are
chirping the sun will be a
warm day so between t shirt you
so causalities we quite often
then think  you also in the modality
you think in terms of
possibilities and impossibilities possible of course that
it still rains impossible it is
not and so on and so forth so
you always think in these four groups
and not just once a day but
constantly yes which is the condition of
the possibility of being able to think at all
can self-confidently he says that's
the index that's the index
now  g of all originally pure
concepts of synthesis that the
mind contains a priori so here
again this important word a priori, that
means our twelve categories are
already in our heads beforehand and with
these categories we judge the
sensual journeys that come in to us
let's start to put the world in
order unfortunately himself doesn't have a
single example for this that he brought in his
thick book he himself commented on
it and said well of course what
should he do
great now
bring another example the book he has over 1000  pages
rather don't want to lengthen any more
but i think he was a
bit too cowardly because it's
really hard to apply these wooden
categories to reality
i
've tried to implement this for you as an example
enjoy this with caution kant would
probably die
wrinkle your eyebrows and get wrinkles in your forehead
when this is heard  but i did
it so that it becomes clear to you how that
can be meant,
yes, the upper part, you
understood that, you were on it, you make the
perceptions, you arrange everything in space and
time through the apricot
visual forms, yes, and now that was
the transcendental aesthetics
coming now  let's go to the transcendental logic
now comes the mind now discount
really the entire thinking apparatus veritas
is wrong it wasn't exhausting how are
you because the spatiotemporal you take
it was passive but this here that is
your activity now the strict tanja hit
now let's check the quantity now
we everything we see on the
quantity the quality the relation and
the modality because
the mind we already had that
the mind it compares and it separates the sensory impressions with the help of the
twelve categories
unity multiplicity al hayat reality
negation limitation inherent causality
community possibility  since its
necessity and only a  m in the end
a realization comes out then a
realization comes out and that's how the
thinking apparatus of all people
all over the world works exactly the same and now comes an
example imagine
we learn read that don't
relax yet imagine
us  driving on the freeway you are driving
on the freeway in your car relatively
quickly maybe even
the convoy traffic
or maybe that's quite normal
you lose driving on the freeway
suddenly you see
an obstacle on the road some distance away, 40
centimeters in size, about half a meter
rectangular on the street so 40 x 30
cm otherwise a cuboid somehow on the
street that and you know they're rushing
towards it now is of course the highest
railway
can be dangerous and now
in a flash you put
your twelve categories from kant over
the raw sensual
impression get the ohe sensual
impression this thing is now from the
categories processed separately
and assigned in a flash yes the
thing belongs as a unit to the
brown-red objects you see yes there
is something brown-red then
think in the category of plurality many
wooden blocks and many wooden boxes are
brown-red but also many target stones
are brown-red  then you think in the
category of heydt all wooden blocks are
heavy
and solid the bricks are heavy and solid and then comes your
first judgment of the judgment on the quantity
yes the quantity of the thing is unfortunately
quite considerable that can be damn
heavy then the second reality
that things  on the street measures 40 x 20
cm
then think negations yes the thing
on the street can't just be
run over can't negate the
main if i could just overtake
dangerous then think in
limitation the thing on the street
doesn't belong there because you  yes see
the whole street and normal
things are limited the  se in such a way to
perceive the horizon of experience then comes
your second judgment the thing has the
quality of a massive obstacle and
it goes on inherent subsistence of the
heavy substance of the thing is
inherent break through the windshield
yes then put the next category
on top of it, namely the category of
causality and you think  if
i don't brake or swerve in some way
then the
brick or block of wood may have
a life-threatening effect on my
vehicle and me yes so cause effect
feeling chosen it ca
n't be old on it and that flies to the
side quite actually on it and up the
house  and through the
windshield yes interaction
my fast driving and the heavy
thing add up to an even greater one
I had the impact you know
the children throw stones from the autobahn
that would make the impact even
higher because the cars just drive fast
otherwise I will be very approx  Honestly yes, and
this interaction we always think of
in interactions as well, a
category that we often use in everyday life
and so we finally come to the
third judgment, the relation, i.e. the
relationship of the thing to me and the car,
is given to a large extent, i.e. what is
there  what happens to the red part what my
senses can perceive through the
processing of the categories give me the
judgment that there actually
what affects me what of it is possibility
impossibility it would be possible that the
object is thrown up hits me
or that it is thrown up and
shows flies past  but it is not
impossible that it hits me then
i think in the category of being there not being
no doubt the thing is there is
blocking the way so the
category is completely clear then i think in
the category of necessity by accident it
is necessary for me to do that  obstacle
to react yes with a giant fall
I could shoot it away  he it
doesn't make sense
to leave it to chance then my final
judgment is the modalities are such that i
can't rely on chance
that means i have to brake yes and
what i have just told you
will of course happen much faster otherwise you
will  they will laugh and
say yes in the meantime i
drove onto that part a long time ago no
it's not like that they turn the categories
much faster of course and now
comes the point now you think
you're going to pull the brakes but in the second leg
that's it  people who were tight when
they brake gibson
panic and at that moment they
suddenly see that the brown-red object
is moving from left to right and is moving and in a
flash they rebuild their categories
over unit the 40 centimeter long
thing belongs as  move unit to the
brown-red objects left to
right much sorrow many animals
are brown-red  small animals can
move rabbits squirrels foxes are
brown red al hayat all animals have
bodies causality
if the brown-red part is
actually a rabbit or a fox or a rabbit or
whatever yes then maybe i'll be lucky and it'll
still come over the
road  until i get there i see
everything yes and while i am thinking about
it happens but what else is
bad error messages come back
from the brain yes because
remember what does the mind do
the mind always does the following comparing something as
a feature with a thing
means judging the thing is the subject
the feature the predicate so we the mind
that judges and the judgment is
lightning fast and he always did the
following he compares the object with
the predicate of the object this
brown-red part and the predicate is in
the case that we say it is  an animal
the brown-red part is an animal yes now
but if we show the categories again
about lengths yes then means
if we
put the categories on top then the following happens that we
see damn
animals animals hop beastly bring
animals move yes well nose will the
hopping rabbits would always
recognize the ipad too and a fox
or a squirrel we would on
tail but recognize the brown-red part
none of that so it's not an animal
so we can't assign the characteristic
yes to the subject brown-red style what
moves we're already in a
panic and now what's even
worse is we see how the
brown-red part  rises and flies back and forth
yes and immediately we have
to lay the categories above it again at lightning speed
yes the thing belongs as a unit to
the red objects which are almost
square move from left to
right and in the air a
lot of them fly back and forth again too  the next
category multiple many birds brown red
many paper bags are brown red all
hall sweep kö  if they fly up
paper bags can be whirled up
reality the flying thing 40
centimeters square negation not a
bird up to 40 centimeters and square
the thing is not a bird limitation the
paper bag does not belong on the street
causality if a paper bag is caught by the wind
this can be the reason
that they are in the  wind play flies back and forth
in hands the paper bag
inherently contains little mass
and is therefore easily spun back and forth
possibility impossibility
it would be possible for the bag to
smack my pane obscuring my view
but it is completely impossible that
the bag slams through the window and can hurt me
the moment i have recognized all this thanks to
my categories i can relax and i
just kept going and the bag joke then
gone or it goes on the window in
milan wipers i am
relaxed and  why am I suddenly
relaxed thanks to my twelve k  categories
of immanuel kant that's
how you have to imagine it, of
course, kant as a trans the dental
philosopher didn't ask himself where
the categories really are where they
come from what that is content is
interested in what is the condition of the
possibility that this
multitude of raw sins materializes at lightning speed
can arrange impressions and that is only possible
with these categories
all sensual perceptions are
under the categories as conditions
under which alone the diverse
can come together in a consciousness
if we had not these great categories
in which will attac be able to think everything through
we would not be in
the situation the variety the
multitude of these stimuli and things
that bring us to be arranged in a flash
well
now we are already coming to the end of
this book he now draws a very
radical conclusion he says without
sensuality there is no object yes
completely clearly if we do not see  when
we sleep  en if we do
n't perceive anything at all we have no
object and without reason
no object can be thought of either so
both are necessary sensuality and
the reason he says
thoughts without content are empty perceptions without
concepts are blind then give you
one last example or maybe
first  another thing for the
historians of philosophy after a small subordinate clause i think philosophy normally avoids historical statements
but for the sake of completeness
at the time there were the so-called
mp lists from kant they said only that is
true what we can really see feel
smell only that is the
reality then there was  it was the
rationalists they were other
philosophers they said no
the reality outside it can
all deceive us everything can be
deceptions sensory illusions father
morgana etc the senses are unreliable
only what we think up logically in our
heads that is the truth only what
we have in our heads  and  nd the law firm no
both are wrong and a bit
right it ultimately includes
both what we see the sensual
perception the views the action
through the senses and on the other
hand the logical thinking a priori
so a priori what we already
have in our heads and apostles  july what we find outside
and both there is more
knowledge if only one of them is missing
there is no knowledge
that is the result of an investigation
so thoughts without content are empty
one last example i told you
now paint thoughts or concepts we
can also use concepts  concept
without content is empty all cuts
can you imagine something
you laugh you grin no one
can imagine why because you
have no content for this concept maliki don't even
see let's say
all cuts all cuts don't help if you that
stays here thoughts without  contents are
empty that remains completely empty the word yes
if the pole were there e  s different that
means pancakes in Polish yes and
but for you no chance so a
thought without content remains a
perception without concepts it is blind to the
perception without concept is picture is
can not give an example
take a one and a
half or any preliminary stage to the
human being der  not even the one who
has fully developed the logic and the categories and everything
he suddenly pulls
a pancake that sizzles it
should look yellow sloppy
but he has never in his life been able
to use the categories
when he still has his animalistic
the preliminary stage is the world championship would never occur to the
idea that the symphonic musicians
couldn't bring it to a head do you
understand the term
pancake could not bring it to it
because the logical visual
forms because the logical
categories go in the head that's why
you need both you need  so to speak, on the
one hand the object and on
the other  side we need
the mind that first processes the object
for cognition, so every
cognition has two sides, so to speak, on the
one hand, they must be sensory impressions,
here are high sensory impressions that are arranged in
space and time, yes, and they
can only come from the object and on
the other side
there must already be a priori in the
mind a category categorial working
criteria that we can organize it and
this result now had two very
big consequences that are still
valid worldwide today that you think too harmlessly from
every level blissful but
through these findings
natural science has a hand
gained a working basis that made it possible for
researchers all over the world to
compare their findings
because all of a sudden the researchers knew clearly
it only works the way the theory
maxi was thought out as well here in the
mind with the category let’s say
with causality mostly
researchers work and
know  nschaftler with the causality it
may be so good you have to be able to prove it
on the object by looking at
it there must also be an
object with which i can
experimentally show exactly that it is
exactly as i
thought it up in my head some even do it the
other way around  they try first
develop then make the theory they first
develop the theory and then do the
experiment but that doesn't matter both
must work and the experiment must be
repeatable set an example when
a scientist
works let's say with his head
with his transcendental logic and
sets the category  of causality
and says yes
heat causes the molecules to
slowly dissolve and become liquid and
if i now take a block of ice and
heat the block of ice then it melts
and if i heat the water again
and for even more heat at a
certain temperature there's  water vapor
and then the molecules dissolve even
more  and then there is water vapor that
would be a theory that you can come up
with in your head with the help of causality
but it shows that it really
becomes knowledge you have to
be able to show it to a block of ice
again
and again and that this idea that basically
both belong to knowledge  the a priori
what is in our head and the logic
and the apostle july look at yes
that will make it clear that
we can see that gives first
knowledge and on this
working basis the whole of modern
natural science took off and it
has this enormous triumphal procession also of
technology  and given to the machine to
this day to this day and the second consequence for
which has had to suffer quite a bit because
it was very much criticized was
religion what kind of a consequence does
that have for religion when you say
cognition only comes about if at the
beginning the object  the senses they
adorn
yes
how about god
yes god goes with god something can  you
really recognize god is there a
knowledge of god no there is not
really how can there not be
because you can't see him you can
or he has already
seen god or smelled god or tasted
god or felt my god is not an
object of  perception and because we can
not perceive it does
n't help if we only think about god
without perception without intuition
an important part of knowledge is missing
that's why hand says you can't prove god
there is no evidence of god
everything is nonsense at the time of kant
Of course there is a lot of God's proof, for
example some said they only
took the category of
causality here and said well if
everything in nature is a cause-
and-effect structure and once the other one comes up against
then there must have been a first
impulse and that  must have been
god as an unmoved mover he brought
movement into the world that
is pure  logical possibility to prove god
but can shows that is
not enough that is far too little and because there is
no conception of god there is
also no god is proof yes the
result was that this beautiful little
booklet brought itself in
it was initially forbidden  in
many countries on the index and
throughout his lifetime, his
writings critical of religion were not
allowed to be taught at
universities, that was the result
now, but he could still do something that
he perhaps did not want at all,
namely by saying that the
criticism of  pure reason changes
that we as
humans have to admit to ourselves that we
cannot recognize pure ideas like god with our reason
this has made us unemployed as philosophers, so to speak
, if what
do the philosophers think about
mostly they also think about
ethics or overweight about  all these
things and you know you can do it yourself h  at
yes also invented the categorical imperative
yes
and now of course the big question is
yes if philosophy is only
allowed to make statements about real
knowledge then it may no longer
say about justice about ethics about
action orientation because that is
no real knowledge and there
can be  once again a nice
check he has
written a second book and that
is no longer a critique of pure
reason but whether live parachute here
that means a critique of practical
reason and three has done something very
interesting he says well he
couldn't go back  so it is
written buchmeier said well
in theoretical terms it is not
possible to sound real knowledge about
action orientation about ethics about
justice about god about everything
but in practical terms
with practical reason very well yes
we can't really
ultimately prove that as knowledge
but  i  n practical intention we
can definitely also make statements with
practical reason what we can do together
the practical intention quite simply
if we live together as a society
here we have rules you
can’t just knock someone
down and take something away and so
on and why aren’t we allowed to do that
because it would simply be impractical if
everyone accompanied the other with
practical intentions we have made a lot of
practical rules for our life
together of
course you can't
see justice justice has no perspective
you could say yes a mother
who is now distributing the chocolate to three
children  you can see how
they are distributed you can see that the
turnips are the same size but ultimately
you can't really see justice
you could now measure in the
millimeter range whether they are really the same
size we could say
distribute justice
you can see here the distribution of justice
see clearly but in the end you
can of course see the correctness
they can't see that also the
categorical imperative has no
view but with a practical
intention even if it can't be
proven it's necessary that we set
practical rules for living together and
that's the second thing  book i can
now only briefly summarize this in five minutes
because it is easy
to do it belongs to his second major work,
so to speak
said yes and now it gets exciting
let's start with his
categorical imperative act so
that the maxim of your will at any time at the
same time as  principle of general
legislation could apply that
can most of you
know it I don't have to say much about
it it's about how we act the
maxim is the principle yes so that
the principle of our will also become the
basic principle of general action
one  general legislation
can become so that  we should act in such a way, so to speak
, that the goal of our actions
needs the goal of all others who
could act in this way, so it's about exemplary things about individual things, it's
exciting, the result is that the
result of this little book is exciting
for us now, but how does that happen and
i can only recommend that to you that
reads like a thriller yes and there are
things that are also interesting for all of us
all over the world in the end there are only five
ways to act five ways to act
well and in an exemplary
manner the first distinctive age-
old the first action orientation
that's one  students
mostly have that’s what’s called
hedonism yes
looking for pleasure avoiding displeasure the
imperative would be live so that
you hate gaining pleasure and
avoid displeasure is and if we’re
honest we’re not the only ones who do that I’m
also happy to make it clear but what  does that have a
disadvantage why can't that be a morally
valuable principle of action and
can the good ethical
action orientation what's the
disadvantage if we all
behave like that
yes
, you see, of course, of course, have no
disadvantage pleasure principle well it's completely
clearly recognized would say a principle which
only refers to subjective to the subjective
condition of receptivity to pleasure
or displeasure  founds can never make a
practical law why it's
actually quite clear you want to say let's say you
want to pay taxes the next
person doesn't want to then you think about
introducing more taxes or not
it won't go well or someone
is fed up and wants to  starts to
torment him it's nice yes he does
what he likes but the tormented one for
whom nothing is of course terrible
the economies inflicted and that's why
it doesn't work that can never be
an individual law yes he
says so tourism doesn't make any sense as a
good orientation to action  now there is
the next one that is called
util  we also do itarism on
everyday life
, john stuart mill goes back to
and some others come from the
anglo-saxon area and ritas what
does the litas of benefit mean yes the benefit
and that means the action imperative you
should act in such a way that your action
results in the greatest possible benefit  and leads to the
greatest possible benefit
we also make it clear in everyday life
we ​​think about
what do i buy something i don't buy what is of
use to me what is of no use to me some
even think about using the subway when
i go to the station is what
if i use a ticket  or
let's talk about the money how much
does it cost if i got caught and so
on and so forth disadvantage of the
principle
clear what is for some as with
tourism goes back to
epicurus by the way hedonism also with
utilitarianism there is basically the
same disadvantage is  what is good for one can be
harmful for the other jan
now but the utilitarian have
the philosophical mu  lti guitarists
were of course not so naive that they
said everyone must do what is
most useful they said that
their ethical principle
can be exemplary for action orientation it
must be that you should act in such a way
that through your actions you get the
greatest possible benefit for  all scored
for the greatest possible number so you have
to act in such a way that you achieve
the greatest possible benefit through your actions,
not for yourself but for the
greatest possible number
, well, politicians often think like that
too, if
they plan a subway stop, then I had to
they shouldn't plan there where they live themselves, they should
make the subway stop where
the largest possible number can use this subway
what's the disadvantage of that
that actually sounds very good
what's that  disadvantage it also has
a disadvantage
yes what could be the disadvantage that be poor
and elitist so nice if we so
ha  ndelt yes are shrug the shoulders
yes the disadvantage so knew is of
course not satisfied with that either and
i will tell you what kant
wrote or i might give myself a
first example of
the
utilitarian will say yes
you act so that the largest possible number
so let’s say that  falcon benefits
from that thinking in the national state
one acts so that the whole nation benefits
greatly from it and that is of
course very very dangerous because the
minorities can suffer great
harm one example is quite
drastic example is
national socialism if you look
at national socialism there  were
actually handicapped and a
utilitarian benefit assessment classified as harmful to the
people because they actually
cost too much you have to
imagine that yes and there you will find in the
völkischer Be Beobachterer sentences like a
severely mentally handicapped it costs the
national community over 60,000 reichsmarks
a year and does not control  s so there
was radical agitation against these minorities very early on
and it is
actually unbelievable now that the
70,000 disabled people killed in
a euthanasia program in one year are so
unbelievable because
public health and the benefits for many are of
course greater because then they no
longer pay  under such
perverse arguments and that is
the huge danger of utilitarianism
and that is why it is said that the human being
and every being in general exists
every reasonable way, so the human being
and in general every reasonable being
exists as an end in itself and
not as a mere means for any
use, i.e. that  is also a very
decisive sentence here
human dignity is laid down as a basis man is an
end in itself who does not serve a
higher purpose i.e. the nations, the people
or the world community man
himself is valuable is an end in
itself and one must not use him
for anything  use other  and that was of
course a great criticism by
hand that's why utilitarianism is
n't good either now there's we're
almost done there next there's the
so-called reimannism of
aristotle aristotle has
set up a great action imperative
said no, people act
really well  only if you act
virtuously and
looking for harmony under moniz also means having luck
by the way hedonism is the
search for happiness communism too but
the harmony of aristotle is happiness of the
soul and we only achieve happiness of the soul
if we implement our
virtues
and in our actions  our
cardinal virtues but from life yes then
we achieve inner
satisfaction spiritual happiness and
at the same time we act well these virtues are courage
bravery
cleverness and justice they are
always defined a bit differently over
time other
cards have taken precedence in the old ones but with
arist  oteles crime novels are this direction
and modesty was also there
so there is a series of doing and the
man who lives all his virtues
acts in an exemplary manner and even then
no one said it wasn't enough even
then but again what did he
have to complain about there  that's nice
if we act virtuously i'll tell you
right
away he says understanding becomes judgment and
what the talents of the spirit may be called
or good and determination
perseverance in resolution are without a
doubt because some intentions are good and
desirable so he says first of all
aristotle has for  quite specific
virtues are very desirable but
now comes they can also become extremely evil
and harmful if the will
that should make use of these natural gifts
is not good now he says
someone who has everything to do can still
act evil if his will is not
good  yes and then brings a very
funny example here in his
criticism d  he practical reason
and he has this example of a bank robber
or a villain yes the bank robber that
of a villain who cold blooded him
his misdeeds so to speak so if
we embellish a bit let's
take a bank robber
if he's very clever then he'll take a
look  the plans of the bank and uses
his cleverness to rob the bank
if he is very brave and courageous
he also dares to enter and
rob these banks and if he
is also very modest and
reserved yes and clever then he
doesn't bounce back  with the money most
bank robbers in germany will
almost wisely spend a lot of money afterwards
because they brag in front of their buddies because
they keep the whole pub free but if someone is
modest and only ever
takes a little money or money is laid aside for the first time
doesn’t touch
and works  only after years of accessing the
treasure then you don't get it so you
can use the virtues in all directions
ngs and therefore warns recognized and
then says that is not enough yes and
then we have another form of
realism legalism what is
that realism lex ligist the law in
latin lex the law
therefore is the imperative very briefly you
should act like this  that you always
behave in such a way that you don’t break any laws
you should always behave in accordance with the law
then your actions are good
and you didn’t recognize anything about it of
course it’s important even the
children are already learning there aren’t
just allowed to take something with them in the supermarket
or  there just open the chocolate
and eat but secure the
law of ownership and
that it has to be paid for by
mum and so on and so forth but or
whatever everyone has to obey the
laws in the state actually nothing to
object to that everyone  the
laws hold but here too
kant says no again that's bad too
because it's a hetero nomi
ges  guild ethics that means
we are told from the outside what is good because our actions are
only as good as the laws are, even if we always act according
to the laws, and if the
laws are bad, our actions are automatically
bad, again
a drastic one here  for example,
if partisans were in the village,
many nations threatened during the war
that if more soldiers were
shot, then the
civilian population would have to pay,
then 30 people from the village would be shot,
and of course they were there, they were
easy to shoot civilians and have
many soldiers  talked themselves out of that
name war and said well i
had to shoot them or i had
to bring the politically persecuted to the concentration
camp because that was the order of the day i
just kept the laws i
just followed the orders from my
people the lieutenant  has
adhered to the orders of general
and what the politicians by
law sat  agt have yes but that's
not possible you can't talk your
way out of the laws if the laws are
bad we also have to oppose
the laws even that's
implicit in sick and
the realism the birth ethics
doesn't just refer to our
laws  but also on possible
sharia law, for example, or on
christian laws you know there are
devout christians who do not have their
children operated on if
they need a blood transfusion for an
operation because the bible says that
you must not mix blood under
any circumstances and  devout
christians do not
allow blood transfusions or other
areas so the ten commandments
are of course also an ethic of conviction
that comes from outside and can says no
we are only allowed to do that and follow the laws
if we ourselves recognize the laws as
good it actually more
radical attitude that we see here now
in this quote  t
as far as practical
reason has the right to guide us, we will
not consider actions to be
binding because they are gods commandments,
but because we are intrinsically
binding on them, i.e. we follow the
ten commandments of the bible or other
commandments from the bible not just because that
are laws and because we are
legalists but because we still have to
decide for ourselves whether we
should do it or not whether we
are bound by this law or not out of
ourselves we can decide that
yes it is so that the maxim of your
will at all times  at the same time could apply as a principle
of general legislation
so
let's check existing laws to see if it really
makes sense if i act like this and if everyone always acts like
this, whether it's really fair
and good, you can do that everywhere, so
if you're lonely in the desert and
decide what  must behave according to this
maxim you can always always
the categorical i  mperative has
gone around the whole world, not only
the German children learn it in school
, it is taught worldwide and misjudged says of
course if you look at everything now
the hedonism organism
utilitarianism realism then his is
the only thing that is always absolutely
right and always works
maybe at the end what's
funny imagine you break
well it's not that funny
imagine you break in winter now winter is
coming into the ice while
sledding and you're drowning
in this hot thing call help help
now a hedonist would come
by who would save you the hedonist who
lives according to the pleasure principle who would
pull you out so you must be
very lucky that his
hedonistic thinks that I feel like saving him now he
is definitely a
very grateful grip light  have a
schnapps,
maybe he'll see
there's a pretty young girl w
as the rescuers fell in there I feel like
it but they can
also be unlucky and it goes on then
comes the
utilitarian are still
calling for water help help
utilitarianism what use
do I have from it if not in the red
maybe direct it  what kind of damage
could i have isn't it possible
that i only get up when the cold
if i slide in over the ice sheet in
june so if you're lucky it's
the roadster but if you're
unlucky it'll pass by now
the next one will come  is let's say
you are yes and in the sense of aristoteles this
is one who should always live his virtues
and wants to
because you have a better chance that he
will save you because if he is really
brave if he is brave and if
he is clever he will look  also how to
do it, that you save her and then
she falls riding if he
has trained more other virtues let's say
the modesty
z  reluctance and things like
that it could become critical yes and then
comes the legal is the last promised
legal is the one who keeps laws for someone
here of course she actually has to
save her because there could be he who saves
her because he thinks that is a failure to
provide assistance and we could
get him and keep to
the laws so again not get his turn because of
failure to provide assistance
so they will help
but if he comes from a country
the law does not have to exist because it is yes
there is not everywhere it is in
germany and i think also in
france there is not everywhere the
failure to provide assistance in the law where
he there he passes if he has
no legal
obligation to help you at all you understand yes and
now come now you have been
cold soup for ages yes and then come  one
over they call help again help and
what is it is a kanzian and he has
to go by the categorisc  hen imperative to who
knows that the reason for his actions
must now be so good that one could make him a
principle for the actions of all others
who ever avoid
drowning and there is of course
only one thing to do: rescue, which helps you out of
an inner obligation  he
commits himself to help you in
order to raise his own actions as an example to the
maxim for the other all others he
will help you so only
the whole of ghana will help you really well
i have it now at the end a
bit of fun i presented but what
cantons delivered here  has is
actually a thorn in the moral
flesh of comfort
so that by the way i saw it again
out here just before
other drum band is through the newspaper
box where you voluntarily throw money in
and can take the newspaper
also stole another newspaper and
that works of course  not even if
no one is watching them and no one sees it
according to the categoris  something imperative
must not do because you know if
everyone now takes the newspaper without
paying yes there he is starving they
are rather poor people who then
fill up these boxes at 4 in the morning
so you can't do that yes
and there  is the category categorical
imperative of course strictly small things
or to throw something away or
not yes if you think to yourself yes what would happen
if everyone now throws that away can you
really raise
my actions to the maxim or is the maxim of my actions
for all those or if you  him are yes
and you just have to have yes should
i pee in the lake then you think it's
a big lake and if i
now made the level of the rhine it
doesn't stand up to it but that can you anna i would
think i can that the
maxim of my actions  need to pee in the lake
actually make it a general
law that everyone pees in the lake
if they feel the need
and i want that after all n  ot or
take the swimming pool, you
see, and of
course it also plays a huge role in politics, so
the categorical imperative at the
climate conferences is that every
politician usually first tries
to protect their economy and the
emission values ​​so far  to keep up
that it is allowed to make so many emissions
that an economy still works
because he thinks in his economic
egoism and according to kant it would of
course be so that one thinks what is
the best way for the global community
my actions my emission values ​​​​that
I set are exemplary  for
the actions of everyone else, yes, which
emission values ​​do I have
to stand up for so that my actions can become the basis for
everyone else's and if everyone had
these emission values, what would
be best for the world that would be a
categorical imperative how politics
should think and there it is  of
course leave us something that
actually is an e  norm explosiveness
well
maybe
none of us yet yes can always live according to the
categorical imperative is completely
clear so we also live good
things the touristic and according to the pleasure principle
is completely clear yes good in this sense
thank you for your
attention and
wishes  nevertheless have an
exemplary nice afternoon in the
sense of the categorical imperative many
thanks thank you very much
[applause]